All right, let's talk about something that
I think probably some people in the audience
are just not going to be thrilled that that
I'm talking about, but this upcoming election
is of such utmost and total importance.
The removal of Donald Trump is such an existential
imperative that we can't have anybody handing
Trump any gift, any fodder whatsoever that
he may be able to use to get himself reelected.
And unfortunately, yesterday, Donald Trump
was handed a gift as a video went viral of
a group of Black Lives Matter protesters in
Washington, D.C., surrounding and intimidating
and screaming at a random woman who was just
sitting outside at a restaurant and demanding
that she raise her fist and show solidarity
with protesters.
We have video.
It's literally video of a mob surrounding
a random woman and screaming at her.
This is the opposite of what we need right
now.
This is exactly the type of video that the
right can use to criticize protesters.
And quite frankly, this is perfect video to
help Trump.
If you were trying to help Trump, this is
exactly what you would stage in film.
I'm going to show you the video.
I'll describe it.
It's a crowd of video.
It's a video of a crowd of people with fists
raised, a really tightly gathered around a
woman who's sitting outdoors at a restaurant
in D.C.
They're so close to her that she's literally
leaning back with her head almost up against
the wall.
Take a look.
Take a listen.
If you're not watching.
Here's another video, a little more zoomed
out where you can see sort of the bigger picture
scene, you're also going to see a protester
asking that white people step forward.
I guess they thought the optics of white people
intimidating the woman would somehow be better.
I don't know.
Take a look.
So listen, guys, there's just no defending
this.
We shouldn't even.
I don't want anybody to even try to defend
it.
We were better off if we just say this isn't
the right strategy.
This is a disaster.
This is stupid activism.
This is counter-productive activism.
And I know that there are going to be some
people who are going to write to me and they'll
say, David, you privileged?
Whatever.
How dare you criticize this?
Protesting shouldn't just be when it's comfortable.
If this woman is sitting outside having, you
know, a 14 dollar cocktail, I don't know what
she's having.
But what you know, whatever it is, people
are going to say, who are you to say it's
not okay to make her uncomfortable?
Activism isn't always comfortable.
We don't if we only protested when and where
they say it's okay, we would never get anywhere.
What I'm telling you is that this is counterproductive.
The woman who was surrounded said later she's
with the protesters.
She's previously marched with protesters.
But here she felt under attack.
These are not only intimidation tactics, they
are dumb intimidation tactics.
The they are handing gifts to Trump when they
do things like this.
There's no upside to this.
She was already on their side.
I don't know of anyone who was lukewarm who's
going to see this and say, oh, I like now
I'm joining the movement.
The movement gains nothing from this.
It doesn't help the cause.
Now, does it maybe make the protesters feel
good in some way?
Maybe I'd feel terribly if I was there intimidating
this woman.
Maybe there are people who feel good when
they do something like this, but it achieves
nothing.
We don't have to talk about the morality or
the ethics.
We can just be pragmatists and and recognize
it plays directly into Donald Trump's hands.
I actually am asking myself, do they care
if Trump gets reelected because there's a
reality?
I don't know the specifics of of the politics
of these individuals, but there are people.
Who see Biden as just as much the enemy as
Donald Trump.
And if that's the case, they may not care
that this type of thing plays directly into
Donald Trump's hands.
If that's the case, that's a big problem.
It's a different problem.
And I would disagree with them.
And, you know, we could figure that out.
I've discussed that problem ad nauseum for
months.
But why are we giving people ammunition?
What are what are we doing?
This is completely counterproductive.
And fortunately, you know, I wasn't sure.
I haven't seen everybody's reaction to this.
You know, people that that work in MySpace.
But for the most part, most of the people
who I follow on Twitter on the left who have
tweeted about this have denounced it.
And that's what it just needs to be.
This is not what we're advocating for.
This is bad.
This doesn't help the movement.
This helps Donald Trump.
This
is
a bad idea.
Hopefully, that will
be
the consensus.